do you need more optimism in your life
if you've clicked on this video you're
already on the path to becoming more
optimistic because it shows you have the
intention and you have awareness of the
fact that you could use a little bit
more so today i will be sharing with you
the secret to becoming an optimist
and it is important to know that it is a
characteristic that you can adopt or
develop you're not born pessimistic it's
a pattern of thinking a habit of the
mind so let's dive into how to retrain
your brain to think positive step one
pause
as a nurse the word burnout comes to my
mind on this one when you're tired and
overwhelmed it's difficult to think
clearly
let me know in the comments have you
ever had an argument when you're
exhausted and you don't even know what
you're arguing about anymore because you
just can't think clearly or even trying
to solve a problem during a pounding
headache after not having slept the
night before take the time to step back
from the situation so that you can face
it from a fresh perspective
life can be rough it's okay to cry or
feel angry or upset sometimes
our emotions make us human but at some
point you have to make the decision to
step away
breathe wash your face get the sleep you
need and pause
for me when i've had times that i want
to explode on our kids for example i
physically step away from the situation
and this leads me to step number two
which is spiritual care make time for
this every day
for me this means prayer for some it
means meditation and taking a few
minutes to deep breathe and focus on
breaths
being still and silent
try to find all the positives in your
current situation make a list and if you
can actually write them out
the beauty of life is that there are ups
and downs this helps us to grow and
learn new things even though it is often
painful or uncomfortable before we
continue to step number three if you
like this video so far don't forget to
thumbs up and subscribe for more videos
like these step number three is
gratitude psychologists believe that
people who are grateful tend to be
happier than those who are not and can
actually be healthier as well because of
the reduced amounts of stress hormones
that trigger inflammation and disease
gratitude is associated with optimism
because we focus on appreciating what we
have instead of constantly desiring more
have you ever wanted something so much
and then once you got it it really
didn't bring you joy
i'm a sucker for journaling so my advice
would be to write a few things each day
that you're grateful for to really make
it a habit schedule it in your calendar
at a specific time each day such as when
you first wake up before you go to work
or before going to bed
a wonderful way to begin this habit is
to practice gratitude as the first thing
you do every morning because it can help
you start your day off on a positive
note
even if you did hit the snooze a few too
many times i have to include this along
with gratitude and it is to give
it doesn't have to mean money oftentimes
the most meaningful and rewarding gifts
are not monetary it's your time it's a
heartfelt compliment it's serving others
when you shift your focus from receiving
to helping others and giving not only do
you not have time to think about your
sorrows but by consequence you often end
up feeling happier and more optimistic
because you start to see that you do
make a difference this is incredibly
rewarding so find ways every day to
serve someone else or make someone else
smile steps four and five i've mentioned
in a previous video but these are so
important for developing more optimism
hang around with optimus and stay away
from pessimists a pessimist has a knack
for seeing what could go wrong and
believes that a virtue that he or she
can see how things really are someone
once told me
realism is just a socially acceptable
form of pessimism an optimist however
believes that even if things are bad
they can change and they themselves have
the ability to create change
you might have heard the saying you're
the average of the five people you spend
the most time with if your co-workers
are gossiping or constantly complaining
stop eating lunch with them in the break
room remove the negative nancies from
your life or limit contact with them
no offense nancy
step number six move and rest
go for a run stretch or go for a walk
this gets you out of the hamster wheel
and can help shift your focus it can
also give you more energy and release
hormones called endorphins which make
you feel happy exercise is a great way
to help you feel your best so that you
can think your best
on the flip side your body also needs
appropriate rest so look at your
sleeping habits and find ways to make
sure you're getting enough of it it's
difficult to feel positive and motivated
when you're running on empty and lastly
step number seven positive self-talk
this one takes a lot of practice but
it's crucial avoid saying things such as
i'm so stupid or i'm so clumsy you did
something that was stupid or something
that was clumsy but you are not those
things
those decisions do not define who you
are make it a point to be more aware of
those kinds of thoughts and immediately
replace them with something positive
when you think to yourself i'm dumb or i
can't do this replace it with i will
improve
i can do this positive self-talk is
actually the hardest one for me and let
me know in the comments which of these
is the hardest for you i hope you find
this information to be helpful if so
give this video a thumbs up and
subscribe so that you won't miss when i
post a new video make sure you hit that
bell so you'll be notified every time i
post a new one
thank you so much for watching and i
can't wait to hear from you see you in
the next one
bye for now
[Music]
you